Now that it's here, it will never let you
go.
On October 28, Sony Pictures unveiled the
first trailer for the upcoming Grudge reboot
an R-rated refresh of the 2004 supernatural
horror film of the same name, which itself
was an American remake of the 2002 Japanese
horror classic Ju-On: The Grudge.
Like the 2004 version of The Grudge and the
film it was inspired by, director Nicolas
Pesce's reboot of the property roots itself
in the same blood-chilling curse: When someone
dies "in the grip of rage," an entity forms
killing everyone who comes in contact with
it and passing on the Grudge in an endless
cycle.
That said, it should come as no surprise that
the first trailer for the reboot of The Grudge
features several references to the films that
came before it.
These are the most important details in the
Grudge reboot trailer.
Early on in the trailer for the Grudge reboot,
we watch real estate agent Peter Spencer enter
the house he and his wife are selling, head
upstairs, and lean down to look at the bathtub
mysteriously filled with jet-black water.
As he brings his face closer to the tub, a
pair of hands break the surface of the water
and grab the sides of Peter's head.
What the heck just happened there?
Obviously, the entity or entities living within
the house aren't afraid to make their existence
known, and will lash out in any way they can.
It's also clear that one of the ghosts is
taking hold in the same location where a supernatural
beast present in The Grudge liked to hide
out: the bathroom.
Specifically, it was Toshio the dead son of
Takeo Saeki, who killed his wife Kayako after
discovering she was in love with another man.
In the American version of the films, Takeo
drowned young Toshio in the bathtub.
"(speaking Japanese)"
The Grudge reboot director Nicolas Pesce previously
explained to IGN that the drowning motif,
quote, "keeps coming back" throughout the
new film, given that, quote, "the nature of
the bathtub is that part of the initial crime
that started this all was a drowning."
But is the evil spirit shown in the bathtub
within the first Grudge reboot trailer actually
Toshio, or is it another entity entirely?
Pesce noted this time to Collider that the
Grudge reboot takes place at a "slightly different"
time than the other flicks, so there's a chance
that the body in the bathtub is indeed Toshio,
who may have resurfaced in a new location
to continue haunting the innocent.
Pair that information with the fact that the
trailer also includes a shot of what appears
to be a ghostly being peeking over the edge
of the bathtub, and it's looking like Toshio
will make a grisly comeback in the new Grudge
movie.
On the subject of horrifying spirits from
the Grudge franchise, it looks as though Toshio's
slain mother, Kayako, also appears in the
trailer for the flick.
There's a moment that shows a character named
Fiona walking in broad daylight, unaware that
a ghost is behind her.
With her white skin, black hair draped over
her face, and dropped-open mouth, the spirit
bears a striking resemblance to Kayako whose
presence is also felt later in the trailer,
when we see a body tumbling down the center
of a stairwell.
Both fans of Ju-On: The Grudge and The Grudge
alike as well as people who have never seen
the films before will know that Kayako has
a strong connection to stairs: she famously
crawled down them in the most nightmarish
of manners as she was closing in on one of
her victims.
Maybe she's the one who threw the body down
the stairwell, or perhaps her appearance caused
the person to leap to their death.
Pesce has confirmed that the curse happening
in the U.S. is, quote, "connected to the one
in Japan," and teased that it had "been brought"
to the country like a malignant disease.
Pesce told IGN:
"The Grudge is kind of like a virus it spreads
and is contagious.
So much of what we wanted to do with this
movie is show that, yes, you know very well
what's been happening in Japan, but what you
don't realize is this is happening in other
places too, and it's not just contained to
this one house in Japan.
It's here and it's here and it's here, and
it's everywhere."
At several points in the footage, including
the pre-roll stinger, we see a gray-haired
woman on the brink of insanity.
She's first shown laughing maniacally in a
kitchen with blood running down her chin and
neck.
She then pops up looking less human than before
with her hands blackened and curled up, her
eyes sunken in, and her mouth dropped open
in a pained yell.
This character may be a new one in the Grudge
universe, but the actress who plays her has
been at the horror game for decades now.
She's Lin Shaye, a bonafide scream queen who
has appeared in films like A Nightmare on
Elm Street, Critters, the Ouija movies and,
perhaps most famously, Insidious.
This time around, Shaye plays the creepy cackling
woman named Faith Matheson who's clearly affected
by the Grudge in some way, and may even be
revealed as the original owner of the house
where the curse has taken hold.
Did she bring the Grudge to the States from
Japan?
Is she the woman who committed the killing
in the Grudged home?
We suspect Faith will be a major player in
the upcoming movie.
If this first trailer didn't scare you away,
catch The Grudge in theaters on January 3,
2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.